deliveries of groceries and other
products have never been more important
or more in demand but that is putting a
major strain on companies that provide
the service this week Don Dahler visited
a fulfillment center for online
wholesaler boxed to see how they keep
the packages moving inside this massive
warehouse 30 minutes outside of New York
City every day essentials that have been
so hard to come by
sit in stacks as far as the eye can see
employees on forklifts do their best to
get them out the door and into delivery
trucks but even for a wholesaler used to
selling in bulk it's anything but
business as usual chiquan the co-founder
and CEO of boxed says there's a kink in
the supply chain this doesn't much look
like a shortage to me yeah so the supply
chain and kind of how boats are
supplying us is really what needs to be
tweaked we're just basically putting it
down putting on the ground because it's
going out so quickly at this moment
boxed has been described as the Costco
for Millennials it offers big boxes of
items food and household goods without a
subscription for sale solely through its
app and website in a world where people
are being asked to stay home and when
goods are in scarce supply wholesalers
like box have become lifelines to
millions of Americans Fong says boxed
customers typically receive shipments in
two days or less
but an extreme spike in demand about
three weeks ago has put them in a hole
there just now digging out up we found
some items such as toilet paper are
still moving extremely slowly from
warehouse to house that two-week stock
up it's really starting to affect how
fast we move stuff why is it so hard to
get your hands on enough toilet paper to
satisfy the demand it's been even
challenging for us to keep all those
items in stock and so you know between
toilet paper hand sanitizer and wipes I
get text messages from friends and
family that I haven't talked to in years
that suddenly text me and I feel like
I've become the most popular person in
my high school about 20 years too late
you know just like I haven't talked to
you in like 20 years but you have toilet
paper the supply chain of America is
great robust but something that's so
great and so robust can't kind of turn
on a dime they could only fill up and
put so many trucks on the road right
exactly for companies like boxed it's
the best of times and the worst of times
an enormous increase in customers and
brand recognition during a global deadly
crisis Marshall Cowan is retail analyst
for NPD consumers are going to get used
to and actually like some of the
components that come out of necessity
for shopping in this you know homebound
environment the ability to be able to
service the guests during times of real
challenged environment that really
creates a long list of loyalty no one
especially not shaquan could have
predicted this moment he grew up just 20
miles down the road in Edison New Jersey
he started boxed seven years ago
shipping inventory out of his parents
two-car garage the privately held
company now has annual revenues of a
hundred million dollars the
quintessential American success story
and from just very humble beginnings in
a garage to now a fully automated
facility with professionals all around
the country joining us it's been quite a
interesting and humbling ride in
addition to this 250 thousand
square-foot warehouse in Union New
Jersey boxed also has two other
fulfillment centers one in Dallas and
one in Vegas in order to keep up with
demand they've added new staff members
and a third shift in order to keep
workers more separated part of the
increased demand is coming from
municipalities on the day we visited
officials from Hong's hometown Edison
picked up provisions for its emergency
management employees we have people up
in the office now trying to procure a
few different vendors and stuff and a
lot of them they just they can't give us
a date
pretty nice having a neighbor that has a
lot of toilet paper in it so it's good
to have this in our backyard and I even
told a lot of other towns you need
something go through box they were able
to pull through this time
going the extra mile for people as it
were including its employees is part of
the box philosophy in response to the
virus a large bottle of hand sanitizer
sits on every flat surface long
estimates automation requires about 20
percent less human touches of each order
things like this originally designed for
efficiency maybe perhaps more for more
for safety these days but beyond the
immediate concerns company has become
known for its generous benefits for
full-time employees from paid sick leave
to considerable financial support for
weddings and college I grew up in a
working-class family where my mom worked
a minimum-wage part-time job and so with
a lot of our policies I think about what
type of policies would I have said if I
was my mom
setting her own rules of course I'm the
CEO but if I didn't come to work the
next day this business still Chuck's
long but if the folks in the front line
here don't come to work the next day
then we're nothing without them and kind
of living that has been are either the
supply chain implies a connection for
the makers the distributors to the
person in need long believes every link
along the way including theirs is
crucial it's a business but do you also
feel like in a way that this is a public
service now it is we didn't sign up for
them we signed up to be kind of
employees in sending food to people's
homes around the country we get from
folks emailing us saying hey I
physically can't leave the home I'm
immunocompromised my kids are
immunocompromised I'm with an elderly
family member and the service that you
guys are providing us is a critical part
of how I could stay healthy and for us
you know we share those messages with
the folks here and people realize that
you know we've all got to step up in
this in this time for CBS this morning
Saturday Don Dahler Union New Jersey